la nuit tombée bogota a encore une fois
été le théâtre de violences voyant les
derniers protestataires répondre par des
jets de projectiles aux gaz lacrymogènes
tirés par la police
un peu plus tôt dans la journée des
centaines de colombiens avaient décidé
de descendre dans les rues pour le 15e
jour consécutif
objectif de la mobilisation demander du
changement dans les politiques
économiques sociales et éducatives du
gouvernement
mais surtout pour demander la fin de la
répression policière très virulente
depuis le début de la contestation
l'une des conditions préalables pour
avancer dans la négociation était que le
gouvernement d militarise le pays que la
force brute utilisés par la police y
compris les armes qui ne sont pas
utilisés précisément pour contenir la
mobilisation ne soient pas utilisés
cependant le gouvernement ne comprend
pas encore cela ce qu'il faut c'est
qu'ils écoutent le peuple qu'ils
écoutent les jeunes nous sommes fatigués
des mêmes politiciens de toujours pour
calmer les esprits des manifestants ivan
doute ya rencontré les représentants des
jeunes ce mercredi la veille le
président colombien dévoilait des
mesures disciplinaires prises contre 65
membres des forces de l'ordre
nos forces de sécurité agissent dans le
respect absolu de la constitution et de
la loi tous les ordres opérationnels
sont toujours émis dans un cadre
garantissant le respect des droits
humains
et si des violations ont lieu à la suite
de comportements individuels de membres
des forces de sécurité
elles font l'objet de poursuites et d'
enquêtes en parallèle à ces
manifestations
plusieurs barrages routiers ont été mis
en place dans le pays comme ici à cali
l'approvisionnement en carburants
médicaments et aliments se retrouvent
perturbé conséquence certains
supermarchés voient leurs rayons resté
vide et de longues files d'attentes se
crée aux abords des stations service
autre réaction en chaîne induites par
ces blocages
l'accumulation de déchets sur le bord
des routes ici nous avons eu beaucoup de
problèmes à cause des odeurs
ici on ne peut pas dormir la nuit
beaucoup de sans abri ils viennent
fouiller dans les ordures
j'ai déjà dit si c'est devenu un
problème de santé je leur demande de
comprendre que cela peut causer la
typhoïde d'autres maladies attirer les
moustiques et c'est mauvais pour la
santé des gens après plus de deux
semaines de contestation
les négociations entre la rue et le
gouvernement semble être au point mort
depuis le début du mouvement
les affrontements entre manifestants et
forces de l'ordre ont fait 42 morts dont
un policier et plus de 1500 blessés